so it's holiday season my favorite time
of the year but this year is a little
bit different i'm gonna attempt to throw
my first ever kwanzaa gathering as an
african-american woman i really want to
understand what kwanzaa is about so i've
enlisted my chef friend madison to hook
me up with a couple of kwanzaa recipes
and give me the lowdown on what kwanzaa
actually is
[Music]
kwanzaa is not a religious holiday it's
simply a cultural celebration we give
gifts we sing we tell stories and it's
just a great time to come together and
reflect on what we have learned
throughout the celebration so today i'm
just going to give you some recipe ideas
so i like to make smothered chicken and
i also like to make fried cabbage i even
have some cornbread in the cast iron
skillet and it's delicious i'm excited
to see what you come up with and i'm
sure it'll turn out great
[Music]
so let's start with our cornbread we're
going to add three eggs and two cups of
buttermilk mix that until it's well
incorporated you wanna make sure all
those egg yolks are broken up perfect
bring in a large bowl
and to this we're gonna add our dry
ingredients so we have flour cornmeal
salt sugar we have some baking powder
and some baking soda the best part the
cheese a cup of cheddar cheese as well
and we will mix this all together
all right so now we're gonna bring in
our wet ingredients and add those to our
dry ingredients all right and let's mix
this up cornbread is like one of my
favorite dishes honestly it's so
nostalgic to me because my mom always
made cornbread for me and my brother
growing up she always put like coconut
milk in it and a lot of butter so she
kind of made it her own so i love
cornbread
i have my skillet hair it's very very
hot because we're gonna brown some
butter we're gonna throw a half a cup of
butter
let it melt look at it melting so now
let's add in our batter look at that
it's just swimming in that butter ooh
spread it evenly in that pan so make
sure we have a nice even
layer it's going to be the most moist
cornbread you've ever tried
[Music]
all right so let's get started on our
chicken so right here i have bone-in
skin on chicken legs that i've patted
dry and to that i'm going to add some
cajun seasoning now it may not look like
a lot but mind you this chicken is going
to be dredged in a seasoned flour and
then it's going to cook in this homemade
gravy so don't worry so now we're going
to make our flour mixture for our
chicken so i have some all-purpose flour
garlic powder some onion powder salt
some smoked paprika pepper and some
poultry seasoning
so let's mix this all together
now we're going to reserve 1 4 cup of
this flour mixture for our gravy and now
we'll dredge our chicken with the rest
of this so make sure to get both sides
dredged in this flour
this is really going to help our chicken
get nice and crispy and then you
definitely want to make sure you're
shaking off that excess that way we
don't have caked on flour so all of our
chicken has been coated i'm gonna go
wash my hands and then we'll get to
frying all right so now it's time to fry
our chicken i'm gonna add a half of a
cup of vegetable oil too so i'm gonna
put these babies in feel free to use any
neutral oil that you want avocado oil
canola oil anything with a high smoke
point is really going to work well right
here you hear her
i think she's saying i'm ready i'm gonna
flip her
[Applause]
i think she's ready
[Music]
i'm gonna set it aside
this is beautiful
[Music]
so you see all these bits in this pan
left behind by the chicken
that's gonna give you some amazing
flavor in your gravy to start this gravy
we're gonna add
one small onion and a half of a red bell
pepper and we're gonna stir those until
the onions are softened the peppers are
nice and softened and that'll take about
three to five minutes we're gonna add
this to our mixture here cook for three
to five minutes until it smells nutty
and it's nice and golden brown chicken
stock
we kind of want to gradually
incorporate this look at that it already
looks like gravy
let's add some more and kind of stir it
as we go
[Music]
so it's been a couple minutes this looks
really good see that it's gotten a
little bit thicker yeah
all right so she is ready so we are
gonna go in and add our chicken
oh
baby look at that it just makes me smile
oh my gosh we are going to base this
chicken
in this gravy oh my god my heart can't
take it we're going to smother this
chicken and all this delicious gravy
peppers onions flavor
[Music]
let's move on to our cabbage we're going
to add some oil to a pan again using
vegetable oil we have six slices of
bacon here red pepper
our onion
one small head of cabbage hair that i
have cored and shredded all right so
we're gonna let this wilt down a little
bit and then i'm gonna add some more in
and see how much i can fit
our cabbage is looking
so good so colorful i have to go
set up my table kind of nervous never
hosted kwanzaa
[Music]
all right well here it is my kwanzaa
spread i will admit i am pretty
impressed with myself let's call it
madison and hope she's just as impressed
as i am
hey madison how are you hi i'm doing
really well i'm excited to see what you
came up with did i do a good job oh wow
your smothered chicken looks really good
and your fried cabbage is perfectly
chopped so that's great i give you a 10
out of 10 i think it looks phenomenal
and how long does kwanzaa last i know
it's more than one day right so kwanzaa
actually starts on december 26th which
is the day after christmas and it goes
through january 1st and each of those
seven days is represented by a principle
of kwanzaa and why are these principles
important the seven principles of
kwanzaa are umoja hujichakulia ujima
ujama mia kumba and imani and these
translate to unity self-determination
collective work and responsibility
cooperative economics purpose creativity
and faith and the seven principles were
created in order to reinforce community
among african-american people oh wow so
i brought my roommates here to enjoy the
food hi romance are you guys excited to
celebrate kwanzaa i'm super excited stay
true to those seven principles not only
during kwanzaa but throughout the whole
entire year and i hope that you have a
very happy kwanzaa so i think it's safe
to say my first kwanzaa gathering was a
success i've learned so much and i've
gotten to spend a lot of time with my
loved ones i hope you have a wonderful
holiday season
oh yes
[Music]
you